[Musique]
imaginez un pur jus un jus 100% fruit
avec sans eau ni sucre ajouté
oui oui sans eau
avec un fruit particulier un fruit dont
il n'est pas très facile d'extraire le
jus
un fruit connu par nous tous pourtant
depuis l'enfance
ça vous interroge
moi aussi ça m'a interrogé au point de
relever le défi de la production de ce
pur jus
des filles relevées défis réussis après
quatre ans de travail quand même en
France à l'INRA devenu depuis l'inrae
institut national de la recherche pour
l'agriculture l'alimentation et
l'environnement nous avons même déposé
un brevet sur le produit que nous avons
obtenu et j'ai pu commencer à travailler
sur le projet de production de ce pur
jus
le fruit en question
la banane
à l'époque dans les années 2000 ce
projet couchette toutes les cases de la
start-up pagroalimentaire
produit innovants avec une valeur
ajoutée intéressante procédez nouveau
pour l'époque
matière première abondante et bon marché
projette deux fois lauréat du concours
national des entreprises aux
technologies innovantes
et pourtant
ce projet n'a jamais vu le jour ici en
Guadeloupe car il s'est tout simplement
abîmé sur la réalité du terrain
cette réalité économique
le marché des jus reste à manger de
volume
et même avec un produit innovant il
aurait fallu produire des quantités
importantes de jus et exporter pour
pouvoir assurer la viabilité du projet
c'est d'ailleurs pour cela
que la plupart des jus de fruits
tropicaux que nous consommons ici et qui
sont dit de fabrication locale sont
faits à partir de pulpe importés qui
sont beaucoup moins coûteuses à
transformer que des fruits frais
cette réalité économique encore
au nom de laquelle les territoires
insulaires sont soi-disant handicapés
par leur étoilettes les trois tests de
leur marché leur éloignement du centre
nous avons même fonds européens qui nous
est dédiés le poséides le programme
d'options spécifiques à l'éloignement et
l'insularité parce que oui nous ne
sommes plus des Guadeloupéens des
Martiniquais nous sommes des ultramarais
et nos pays sont des territoires ou des
régions
ultra périphériques enfin bref
après 8 ans passés apporter ce projet
j'ai tout de même dû me rendre à
l'évidence
ce purger de banane qui était une
prouesse technologique ne débouchait pas
ici en Guadeloupe sur un projet
économique viable
et vous avez devant vous aujourd'hui une
vingtaine d'années après
le dernier témoin de cette aventure
[Applaudissements]
cette expérience n'ayant pas abouti mais
m'a tout de même appris beaucoup de
choses elle m'a révélé la nécessité de
changer d'angle d'approche et à
commencer à nourrir ma réflexion sur
l'agro transformation qui serait adaptée
à mon pays la Guadeloupe
et c'est ainsi que quelques années plus
tard j'ai eu l'opportunité de travailler
à nouveau à l'INRA mais cette fois en
Guadeloupe et j'ai été sollicitée pour
la fabrication de granulés aliment pour
les petits ruminants à base de feuilles
de manioc poids du bois et le sel encore
appelé chez nous Agadir
ses feuilles contiennent des protéines
elles peuvent donc être utilisées pour
l'alimentation animale
ces feuilles contiennent également des
tanins condensées qui sont des molécules
particulières qui ont fait leur preuve
pour débarrasser les petits ruminants
le parasitisme des petits ruminants sous
dans les pays tropicaux est un vrai
fléau puisqu'il peut causer près de 50%
de la mentalité avant sevrage
ce parasitisme est généralement combattu
avec des molécules de synthèse des
antiparasitaires mais contre lesquels
les parasites développent des
résistances donc ces molécules de
synthèse sont non seulement de moins en
moins efficaces mais en plus elle se
retrouve un peu comme nos antibiotiques
dans nos écosystèmes notamment nos
rivières qu'elle polluent
c'est un inconcé peuvent donc les
remplacer avantageusement
sauf qu'ils ont un petit défaut ils sont
sensibles à la chaleur
et le procédé de granulation
comporte une étape de séchage
au cours de laquelle c'est un homme
peuvent être détériorer
alors en tant que technologue l'équipe
attendait donc de moi que je trouve une
solution pour préserver cette année que
je modélise des courbes de prédiction de
la disparition des années en fonction de
la température
que je cherche une technologie innovante
pour préserver cette année
et là
j'avoue que je me suis sérieusement mise
à traîner les pieds
parce qu'on attendait de moi encore une
performance technologique qui ne me
paraissait pas en phase avec la réalité
du terrain
en effet imaginons
je trouve un procédé révolutionnaire
pour préserver cette année en
milligrammes près évidemment on dépose
un brevet c'est la suite logique et
après on se met à monter une usine
flambant neuve
pour fabriquer ses granulés
certainement avec l'aide de ces
programmes européens
et nous nous mettons à commercialiser
ces granulés pour les agriculteurs à un
prix rémunérateur bien sûr parce qu'il
faut quand même assurer la viabilité du
projet économique
et aussi pour s'assurer un petit retour
sur investissement quand même
quelle belle revanche sur ce projet de
jus de banane non aboutit et après avoir
été madame jus de banane il y a des
surnoms plus facile à porter que
d'autres mais donc après avoir été
madame jus de banane me voilà bien parti
pour devenir madame granulés high-tech
et pourtant
une question ne quitte pas mon esprit
c'est granulé miracle
seront-ils accessibles aux agriculteurs
qui pour la plupart en chez nous sont
installés sur de petits petites surfaces
et dont ils ont du mal parfois attirer
un revenu correct
ce n'est pas sûr du tout
alors cela va dû de grandes discussions
avec mon directeur de thèse puisque
c'est travaux ont fait l'objet d'une
thèse que j'ai soutenu en janvier 2020
et après de nombreux échanges nous avons
trouvé ensemble la stratégie que nous
allions adopter
alors oui nous ferions bien des granulés
à partir de feuilles de manioc de bois
et de leucène mais ce que nous allions
rechercher par-dessus tout ce sont les
avantages économiques sociaux culturels
d'une approche holistique c'est à dire
d'une approche globale de ce projet
regardez nous avons choisi de fabriquer
nos granulés à partir de feuilles de
coproduit de récoltes pour qu'il n'y ait
pas de compétition entre la production
alimentaire pour l'homme et la
production alimentaire pour l'animal
nous mangeons les tubercules de manioc
mais nous mangeons pas les feuilles nous
mangeons les pois dix bois mais nous
laissons les feuilles et le lieu sen
quant à lui c'est une plante barrière
que les agriculteurs peuvent planter en
périphérie de leur exploitation et qui
sert de fourrage d'appoint et de
coupe-vent
parmi les plantes choisies vous
remarquez il y a deux légumineuses le
poids du bois et le sel parce que un sol
ça se nourrit et notamment avec de
l'azote qui est essentiel pour la
croissance des plantes et cet azote lui
il a porté souvent par des engrais
azotés qu'il faut acheter les
légumineuses ont ceci de particulier
qu'elles peuvent fixer l'azote de l'air
dans le sol comme ça naturellement
de ces légumineuses permet donc de
diminuer la quantité d'engrais à ajouter
à amener sur les exploitations et ce
sont donc des pratiques agroécologiques
que nos agriculteurs développent pour
effectivement préserver la qualité de
leur sol
concernant le procédé de fabrication
nous avons posé un postulat nous allons
utiliser le séchage solaire point
une technologie simple accessible et
facile à mettre en oeuvre chez nos
agriculteurs nous nous plaçons donc
résolument dans le concept d'innovation
frugale qui consiste à répondre à un
besoin de la manière la plus simple et
la plus efficace possible tout en
utilisant un minimum de ressources et
vous savez tous la nécessité que nous
avons aujourd'hui de préserver nos
ressources et notamment nos ressources
énergétiques
ainsi notre travail a essentiellement
consisté
à
fabriquer ses granulés
à s'assurer effectivement ensuite qu'ils
étaient efficaces pour à la fois nourrir
et soigner les petits ruminants
et ceci est en fait
nous sommes allés au-delà de ces aspects
techniques et scientifiques nous sommes
intéressés à l'environnement
socio-économique de notre projet
et nous avons choisi de placer notre
procédé de fabrication au sein
d'exploitation pardon placé en système
polyculture élevage
ces systèmes comme leur nom l'indique
permettent des interactions entre les
végétaux et les animaux les végétaux et
notamment les coproduits de récoltes
permettent de nourrir les animaux et les
animaux autour on fait les déjections
animales sont utilisées comme amendement
pour nourrir le sol
ces systèmes intègrent donc les
principes de l'agroécologie et de
l'économie circulaire
principe qui permettent une production
de qualité en quantité suffisante tout
en préservant et en régénérant les
écosystèmes
alors faisons le bilan
l'utilisation de ces granulés dans le
cadre d'un système polyculture élevage
permet de limiter la dégradation du
bilan carbone des sols l'utilisation de
ces granulés permet également de
préserver une biodiversité cultivée sur
les exploitations agricoles puisque nous
allons encourager les agriculteurs à
planter des ressources diverses qui
pourront utiliser dans la fabrication
des granulés
l'utilisation de ces granulés aliments
permet également de réduire les
molécules de synthèse dans nos
écosystèmes
notamment les antiparasitaires et les
engrais de synthèse et enfin nous
pouvons espérer améliorer le revenu de
l'agriculture qui pourra utiliser ses
propres ressources pour à la fois
nourrir et soigner ses animaux
évidemment les avantages séduisant d'une
telle stratégie doivent être mis en
balance avec des aspects économiques
le temps de la transition agroécologique
et le temps de fabrication des granulés
un temps que non pas forcément les
agriculteurs
on pourrait ajouter donc à ce système
vertueux de l'innovation
organisationnelle en mettant par exemple
la disposition une plateforme mobile qui
contiendrait tous les équipements pour
la production des granulés et qui se
déplacerait chez les agriculteurs de
ferme en ferme pour produire ces
granulés in situ
voyez
produire des granulés dans ces
conditions ça n'est pas qu'un produit à
des granulés produire des granulés dans
ces conditions c'est préserver la
qualité de nos sols c'est prendre soin
de la biodiversité c'est réduire la
pollution de notre environnement et
c'est également réduire les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre grâce à
l'innovation frugale
gardons à l'esprit qu'un agriculteur
jardinier de la nature
qui fonctionne selon les principes de
l'agroécologie de l'économie circulaire
et qui est en phase avec la réalité de
son territoire fait bien plus que nous
nourrir
il protège notre maison mère
et nous locataire de cette maison
soyons plus nombreux à être conscient
que les interactions sociales et les
collaborations valent bien mieux que
l'excellence individuel pour construire
cet avenir meilleur auquel nous aspirons
pour nous et nos enfants
n'est-ce pas le moment de reconnecter
nos idées nos actions à la réalité de
notre pays au potentialité de notre pays
et si nous décalions et l'idée en nous
et les réalités en nous vous nous
construisons plus belle divine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]